And now it's the old scout master.
So what's the most important tool in any Swiss Army knife?
Well, the nail file, of course.
Why?
Well, because after you've opened all the other pieces of the Swiss Army knife,
you're going to have at least one broken finger.
Hey, this is my pass, number 138.
Yeah,
Hey.
Well, welcome back to the scout master podcast. this is Clark Green
Looking in the mail bag this week. let's see. Jim Woods wrote in about our post-
it's four ways to be a leader. that was on the blog this week.
He says this is golden. we have troop elections in November.
I'd like your permission to use this on our application.
Well, certainly, Jim, go right ahead, and thanks for being in touch.
Thanks for the kind words.
Mike Lotties wrote in about scout parent problems-
Another post that went on the blog this past week.
Great insights in a world where common courtesy is not all that common.
This is a great primer for new volunteers and a good refresher for those of us who've been around for a while.
Thanks for getting in touch, Mike, and once again, thank you for the kind words.
Jason Reedy wrote in to say hello, I'm a new scout master of a new Boy Scout troop,
Troop 101 in Colonial Heights, Virginia.
Thanks for your blog. it's great. I've spent a lot of time here since discovering it recently
And I look forward to reading it in the future.
Well, thank you, Jason, and congratulations on being a new scout master with a new troop.
Mike Rossender wrote in. he said: I just read your post on the phases of leadership development.
It's a brilliant presentation: clear, succinct and actionable.
I'd like to use it.
Is it your own creation?
If so, how can I contact you to get copyright permission?
Well, thanks very much, Mike.
Thanks for getting in touch.
I'm glad that you're finding that stuff useful
And, folks, you can use anything you find on the blog. that is stuff that I've created.
Alls I ask for is that you attribute it to me,
Tell everybody where you found it and that you don't modify it
And you don't have to write and ask my special permission for it.
You got it right now.
A couple of weeks ago over on Kickstarter, we started with a project called the Stuff Adult Leaders Say T-Shirt
And you know what
It took right off.
We got up to this week, about 50%, and now we're in the home stretch.
I think we've got about 8 or 10 days left.
We still need to get about 30 or 40 more backers to make the project a reality.
Now, Kickstarter project is something that you go and you pledge to,
And if enough people pledge, then the product gets fully funded and becomes a reality.
And the reason that I chose to do it this way is that I don't have the money to invest in a big, giant pile of t-shirts
and then maybe sell them and distribute them over a long period of time,
And it just seemed like the Kickstarter idea is a very good match.
Well, if you're thinking about going ahead and becoming a backer, this is the week to do it,
Because what will happen is that, I think on Sunday, that project closes down
and you can't be a backer after that.
You can't get a t-shirt after that
And, like I said, as of right now when I'm recording, we're about 50% there,
So that's another 30 to 40 people need to sign in and become a backer to make the project a reality,
And you can find out how to do that by going to scoutmastercgcom.
You'll see links in the right hand column to a t-shirt just for us,
And you'll also see a widget that will take you directly to the Kickstarter project,
And I really appreciate those of you who've been backers and those of you who've sent suggestions
about what should end up on the t-shirt.
So this week on the Scoutmaster Podcast, we've got a couple of things.
First of all, in Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less,
we're going to discuss why smart people are often bad teachers.
If you're a bad teacher, that means you're a smart person
Who knows?
But we'll talk about that more in a minute.
And then I've got a reply to an email about Maripatches.
So let's get started, shall we?
Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less.
So one of my contributors, who you hear on the Scoutmaster panel discussion, Walter Underwood,
sent me a link to an article by Burke Camber, who is an engineer
And he has a blog,
And this article is titled: Effective Teaching Is a Long Con.
The central thought here is that smart people are bad teachers.
So how does this apply to Scoutmasters?
Well, you know, if you're reasonably experienced and you're skilled,
you're going to sit down and instruct scouts in a scout skill
or you're training and mentoring your youth leadership.
We have to accept something:
Being smart and experienced and skillful does not make you a good instructor.
It certainly helps if you are,
But you can't get by on being a good instructor or a mentor
just on being smart and experienced alone,
Camber said in his article. he says
smart people like to tell the whole story and end up reinventing the universe
when all they set out to do was to teach a lesson on a single topic.
Telling the whole story is kind of frustrating to the people you're trying to teach.
It's too much to take in all at once.
The smart person tends to forget that they learn the whole story
over years of intense learning and experience.
It's hard for the smart person to let go of pieces of the story,
to consciously admit them, even if they're not of immediate importance.
To me, that's a very fascinating and useful insight for us in our work as scout leaders.
My temptation when I am instructing a skill or I'm mentoring youth leaders,
is to be very verbose and to tell them everything,
To tell them absolutely everything that's involved in the subject.
So you know when this happens, right,
You're instructing or you're mentoring or talking to scouts
and you look at them and you see this kind of either a bored look
or a distracted look or a look that says
I am really hoping he's going to be finished very soon,
Trying to escape, you know,
And as we go through the fourth digression from the lesson or message
that we're trying to communicate. we know exactly what's going on, right?
So a good illustration of this: you're going to teach a scout how to tie a bowling. alright,
Don't start with where the rope comes from
and what kind of plant it's made out of.
Teach the boy a bowling. alright.
If you're mentoring youth leaders, you don't need to talk to them
about every aspect of your experience and leadership
and add in 17 different kinds of anecdotes and illustrations.
You need to get to them a succinct message
about the particular skill or the particular thing that they're working at. right. then
You know, we don't have to give them the whole world and the whole story all at once,
but we can kind of indicate that there's a bigger world out there,
And Campbell calls this leaving a little trail of breadcrumbs. okay,
Walter suggested this and we'll go back to the illustration of tying knots.
So you're teaching a scout to use a square knot
and you might drop a little breadcrumb like this:
The square knot. you know that's useful for joining two ropes.
Rock climbers use other knots that are stronger and easier on tie,
but we're just going to concentrate on the square knot right now.
You know that little breadcrumb there.
Yeah, you know. so you're talking to your senior patrol leader
and you're saying: well, the patrol leader's council needs to have a good agenda
and I would like to see what you come up with for that agenda.
There's a lot of places where you can learn how agendas are made
and things like that. but concentrate on what you're going to do
for the next few meetings and the next couple of addings
and see what kind of an agenda you come up with.
In other words, I've dropped a little breadcrumb there.
There's a possibility that I might learn about how to do this in another place,
or there is another level of complexity or interest or knowledge
that I can obtain about a given subject.
What's great about scoutmasters and adults volunteering and scouting
is the intensity with which they approach the idea of instructing
and helping and mentoring youth.
I think that intensity is great.
What the problem is with that intensity
is a lot of times it gets expressed in a way where it's inaccessible.
Mike Lotties wrote in to the blog on another post this week
and he mentioned a Baden Powell quote that I think is particularly applicable right here.
If a man cannot make his point to keen boys in 10 minutes,
he ought to be shot.
So when instructing and mentoring, we want to focus,
We want to get on to the most useful information
and we don't have to show the scouts the entire world
every time we speak to them.
I think we're going to find out that if we think about this
it'll make us better instructors and mentors
and it will make us more effective in our work as scout leaders.
You're my favorite all-time boy scout.
In 1928,, 19-year-old Paul Cyple,
an eagle scout from Erie, Pennsylvania,
was picked in a nationwide contest
to accompany the first bird expedition to Antarctica.
The story of his life could almost be written
in terms of the merit badges he earned
when he was 14,, 15, and 16 years old.
Dr Cyple has continued to play an active part
in the scout movement.
I wish every boy in America could be a scout
and I'm convinced that every scout
who takes his rank requirements
and his merit badges seriously
will find, as I have, that such preparedness
is the key to many doors.
You're my favorite all-time boy scout.
He's my favorite all-time boy scout.
Find me a letter, send it by name
Email. that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
I had an interesting email discussion a week or so ago
with Frank Maynard.
He got this question
and we discussed it back and forth a little bit
so we're going to talk about it.
This comes from a scout master,
He says. I recently discussed troop meetings
with a scout master from another troop
and I found it very interesting
because they have quite a different approach
to troop meetings.
In their troop the scouts meet for the first half
of the meeting and conduct patrol business
and demonstrations and the like.
The second half of the meeting
the boys attend merit badge workshops
and they have four offered each quarter
and they rotate between the merit badges.
The boys attend merit badges
they are working on for the entire
two or three month periods.
Required merit badges are covered here.
This method's quite different from others
where I've read that merit badge instruction
is discouraged at troop meetings.
I wonder what you take out of this
and if you think it's a workable format
for troop meetings.
Frank and I went back and forth about an answer
and we both agreed: no, this really isn't
a workable format for troop meetings.
I want you to get this message.
Not that you're not allowed to do merit badges
in troop meetings, because I guess there would
be a way where I could understand
that that might be an interesting
thing to do.
If the patrol leaders council decided
that they wanted all to pursue
a particular merit badge and they set it up
and they got a merit badge
counselor
and they worked it out that way.
I can understand
the way that that would work. but setting this up
just as kind of like this is the way
we do business. first of all, we're going to have a meeting
and we're going to have these merit badge
sessions because we need to work on merit badges.
Well, that's not really why we're doing merit badges.
This is the important
message here. Don't look at this
as just like a set policy
where now you're not allowed to do merit badges
in meetings. I heard Clark say that on the podcast
and that must be a national policy
or something like that. Don't think about it that way.
Why do we have merit badges
in the first place?
Why do we have them?
Well, they definitely
communicate useful
skills. Why has
scouting decided that merit badges are done
this way, with counselors and
stuff like that? It seems
kind of inefficient, doesn't it? I mean, the
troop meeting approach that's described here
is much more efficient.
Boys will get more merit badges
and they'll learn more skills.
But what we're missing
what 80% of merit badges are
set up to do? in my humble opinion,
80% of what a scout
gets from doing most merit badges
is derived from the
process.
Now, if he benefits by learning a specific
knowledge or skill, that's great.
But he's got to find
a counselor, He's got to interact
with that counselor, He's got to
learn to manage his time,
He's got to work on getting
those skills And I think
that's a really important process.
Now scouts can do this in
twos or threes and
sometimes they do it in groups and
things like that. I don't have an objection
to scouts earning merit badges whatever
way they can. But if we
look at why we do merit badges,
the way we do them, why it
makes sense to do them that way,
we have to honor the process.
So most of us are pretty far away from
high school. Most of us are pretty far
away from college. at this point,
And here's what I want to ask: you
Try and come up with
a specific skill or piece
of knowledge you learned from college
or a high school class. You probably
be able to locate something like that after you think
about it for a while. But what you really learned
in your career in college
was how to think
and how to go through a process of
learning things. We see that
in the merit badge program too.
You learn how to go through this process,
You learn these social skills, You develop
self-confidence.
Ask any scout about a merit badge that
he earned
in summer camp this summer.
Ask him to give you three or four different
ideas or skills from that merit badge.
He's
not necessarily going to know them
And that's not the single
most important thing about
the merit badge itself.
Yes, we want them to learn skills.
Yes, we want them to be able to demonstrate them.
Yes, some of those skills are very important.
Yes, those skills will develop
lifetime hobbies or maybe even
lead to a profession.
But really, what's important about it
is the process that was involved in it.
Every once in a while you read about a
scout that really gets
excited about merit badges and they decide
they want to complete all 130
or whatever there are right now
And they go through that. and then there's
always discussions about why all he probably
didn't really learn very much from each of these merit badges.
Well, you know what
He benefited from the process.
He benefited from going
through that process
And now he has
basically an encyclopedia in his head
of many different things
And he knows-
not necessarily from
whether merit badge- exactly
how to calculate wind chill,
But he knows that it's possible to do so
and he knows where to find that. information
Process is
really important. when it comes to
the merit badge program.
The short answer is
no. it's really not a great idea
to take merit badges
out of this process that's been designed
and to put them
in a troop meeting.
Yes, it makes them more accessible.
Yes, it makes the whole thing a little bit
more efficient for scouts,
But we need to realize that a major
benefit of merit badges
is in the process:
Music.
Well, thank you for
listening to this edition of the Scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how you can keep in touch.
You can read the Scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there, you can subscribe
and receive updates to the blog by email.
You can also subscribe to the Scoutmaster
podcast on iTunes.
When you do, please leave a comment
or review or a rating.
You can also access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio,
and you can get details about how to do that
at Stitchercom.
Hey, get in touch
either by emailing me at
scoutmastercgathorizonnet
or by going to
scoutmastercgcom
and make a phone call
and record your voice to be included
on a future Scoutmaster podcast,
Scoutmastercgcom.
go to the shout out link. You'll see it in the menu
And you can experience all the wonders
of Scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media
outlets. That's right.
You can join 1700 other scouts
from all over the world by liking
Scoutmaster blog
on Facebook. We're tweeting
at Scoutmastercg on Twitter
and we're on Google Plus
Search for ScoutmasterCG.
The Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast
aren't official publications of the
Boy Scouts of America, nor are they
endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
No, no, no, no. indeed, It's just me.
I have a microphone
and a little spare time
And I like to lend a hand to
Scoutmastercgcom,
Scoutmastercgcom-
and I like to lend a hand to Scout
leaders and maybe have a little bit of fun along
the way. So before we
go, before we leave you once
again, we will hear from
our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Pel. Sir Robert,
Good luck
to you and Group Camping.
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time.